in the meantime las vegas mayor carolyn  goodman also spoke about the milestone  in today's city council meeting  while things are slowly getting back to  normal she expressed her frustration  about businesses  still operating at just half capacity  and children just recently returning to  school some still have not returned to  school  she says businesses that have not been  allowed to reopen are suffering  and questioned the logic behind the  lockdown  mask distancing frequent hand washing  and sanitation are reasonable measures  that health officials assure us  truly make a difference that  is following the science the science  has not proven that completely shutting  down  accomplished anything more than moderate  reasonable precautions she also called  for a return to personal responsibility  saying nevadans are smart enough to  understand what's at stake  and make choices for themselves and  their families